a principios del año pasado apenas unos
días después de la insurrección del 6 de
enero la cámara de representantes de
eeuu votó a favor del impeachment contra
donald trump por segunda vez debido a su
implicación en el ataque al capitolio 10
republicanos se unieron a los demócratas
aunque el impeachment de trump no llegó
a ser aprobado por el senado el ex
presidente arremetió contra los
republicanos que se atrevieron a ir en
su contra
y en la cámara tan rise de carolina del
sur adam kinzinger daniels david valero
y por supuesto la belicista una persona
a la que le encanta ver a nuestras
tropas luchando liz cheney que les
parece a los conocidos como los 10 del
impeachment sabían que enfrentarían
duras batallas a la hora de buscar la
reelección al votar contra trump y las
consecuencias para ellos han sido
masivas sólo uno de anjou house se
espera que sea reelegido en noviembre
agotaré si as de los ocho republicanos
restantes que votaron a favor del
impeachment contra trump cuatro de ellos
han decidido retirarse atribuyendo
amenazas de muerte en su contra y la
falta de apoyo del partido republicano
en cuanto a los otros cuatro incluida la
representante liz cheney todos han
perdido en el último año normalmente
habrían sido candidaturas favorables
para la reelección lo que significa que
como máximo sólo dos republicanos que
fueron contrarios a trump podrían
permanecer en él después de las
elecciones de noviembre